Cái nào cơ quan ngang lộng cú tế về và cá hàng tình tức cú tế,
cú xung đợi tay trình đông đã biệt tại yêu biệt hòa mốt,
đang gây ra cú sức năng lượng nghiêm trọng nhất trong lịch sự hiện đại.
Tuyến hàng ngày chỉ lúc này,
bằng chuyển vào khoảng 20% vào khi tình như nó làm của thế giới.
Tìm thí vị gió bắt đầu cơ của tình công vào cuối tháng 2,
nhiều cơ sơ năng lộng khoảng trọng, nhiều mỏ khi,
nhà máy lập dầu và càng xuất cầu tại cú vực để giảm bạc.
Chỉ trong khoảng 20% tường dầu tôn cầu đã thảm thử biệt loại khỏi thiệt trường,
khiến giá dầu tăng năng mơ năng mề phần chăm,
vừa tù mô chăm mười đô là mì một thông,
khám chỉ có loại chăm gân một chăm sóng hí tư đô là mì một thông,
giá khi đốt tại trường ông ở trường á cũng tăng mạnh,
kéo theo ghi phí sinh hoài và sử dụng giá tăng,
các cú ra là chiểm khai biển phát tiếp kiện năng lượng,
hạn chế tui dùng và điều chiểm hòa đồng kinh tế để gảm á bước một công.
Không chỉ dừng lại o năng lượng,
xuống đột con anh hợp đến nông nghiệp khi có khoảng 20% tường mạnh phần bỏ thí dưới biên lình chế,
bây giờ u re tăng bà mười đi bước mười phần chăm và bộ nhường nhà máy tại trường á phải thích sản sọt,
tui nhiên chương những cạnh báo với thị thải kinh tịch tòn cầu,
sẽ còn tiếp tục ra tăng nghe chống,
ié a tiếp tục cơ kỡ bình chấm rất tần cầu của hà tần năng lượng,
và mở lại yêu biệt hoa mốt để ổn định thiệt trường thần cầu.